i guess let's start with with gone girl
here so
your feature debut and i imagine it must
have been something else
doing something like that with david
fincher yeah the
idea that i always think of is when jake
gyllenhaal
explained that he likes to paint with
people and sometimes it could be a
challenge to feel
like a color so did you find that at all
and what was your experience on that set
like
i had the sort of blessing and curse of
ignorance there was so much about making
films that i
didn't know anything about basic
vocabulary i didn't know i mean it was
absolutely my first film
i had shot two television like three
guest star spots and the pilot of the
leftovers in which i do a speech
so what i discovered about david is that
he's a perfectionist
and i'm a perfectionist and it was my
first film
so if you want me to do 70 takes that's
all the more time i get to practice
and try to do better and once i figured
out you know that and you know i tell
the story on set about sort of saying
remember you hired a beginner and i
don't know
the language so you have to explain what
you're asking me for and he became
such an extraordinary teacher to me he
would show me the frame
why he needed me to do what he was
asking me to do
and when you you can't take it
personally
you have to understand that he's looking
at the whole picture and you know when
he's focused on you but
so many other times he's not and and if
you're going to start
getting taking it personally you're
going to get in your own way and that
doesn't help anybody also
people think of him as a perfectionist
but he loves mistakes because to him
those are often the most human moments
there was a mo there was a scene where
i'm calling ben at the airport and i
i fumbled the phone in the air and then
caught it and then i continued and then
i broke and he was like oh
that was so that was it that was so
great so
i think there's kind of a misconception
about what david's after he's after what
he finds to be the most human behavior
and he thinks actors have a lot of bad
habits
so going into that as a first timer who
didn't know a lot about that
process but it also sounds like david
actually took the time to be a teacher
of sorts
did you ever find yourself in the
situation where as a newcomer
you are afraid to ask what you might
think is a silly question
yes um i'm i'm
one of my crosses to bear is that i'm a
real know-it-all
and it takes a lot of humility for me to
admit when i don't know something
and the older i get the more humble i
get in the easier that's
that's getting to admit that i'm wrong
and i have to say it was really
inspiring to be on set with tyler perry
because tyler who i love would always
say to david
you'd be like i don't know what that
word means and
i i learned from that i learned from
that that let's like cut through the
[ __ ] and and do the work
don't let your ego get in the way so i
learned a lot from the way people around
me were asking questions
and because david made me feel that i
belonged there
that he wouldn't have cast me that's
what you can trust too is that he
wouldn't have you there if you didn't
think you could do it
that i had to just trust that instead